نماذج البرمجة هي مواصفات أساسية بتحدد
كيف البرنامج بيتبنى
وبيتنفذ، وبتوفر إطار عمل
للمطورين يعبروا فيه عن الخوارزميات
وينظموا الكود، وغالبًا بتخفي التفاصيل الدنيا
للهاردوير أو بيئة التنفيذ
كل نموذج بيكون مناسب لنوع معين من المسائل
والهاردوير، وبيقدم
مستويات مختلفة من التجريد
والتحكم. في هذا الفصل
راح نراجع نماذج البرمجة الكمية والكلاسيكية
ونشوف كيف نقدر ندمجها مع بعض لتشغيل الخوارزميات
على
نبدأ بنموذج البرمجة
للحاسوب الكمي. نموذج برمجة أساسي
يعرفه تقريبًا كل مطوري الكم
هو الـ quantum circuit. مش راح
ندخل في تفاصيل الـ quantum circuits
هنا لأن عندنا موارد رائعة كثيرة
منها محاضرة لـ Joan Waters
بس نذكر بس إن الـ circuit مبني من
مجموعة خطوط تُسمى الأسلاك اللي بتمثل الـ qubits
والـ gates اللي بتمثل العمليات على الحالات الكمية
ومجموعة من القياسات
مفهوم برمجة مهم ثاني
هو
هذي الـ primitives بتمثل أكثر المهام شيوعًا
اللي المستخدمين بيحاولوا يعملوها على الحاسوب الكمي
في primitive نوعين متاحين حاليًا
Sampler وEstimator. الـ Sampler بيعطيك القدرة
تعمل sampling لحالة محضّرة بـ quantum circuit
والـ Estimator بيخليك تحسب قيمة التوقع لـ
observable لنظام في الحالة اللي حضّرها الـ quantum
circuit بتاعك. المفهوم الأخير
اللي راح نتكلم عنه في هذا القسم
هو الـ transpilation. الـ transpilation
هي عملية تحويل الـ circuit المُدخل
لتناسب topology جهاز كمي محدد
لتشغيله
على الحواسيب الكمية الضوضائية
مشابه للمترجمات الكلاسيكية
روتين الـ transpilation بيغير تدريجيًا
بنية الـ circuit بتطبيق مجموعة من الـ passes
الآن نتكلم عن نماذج البرمجة الكلاسيكية
في كثير من نماذج البرمجة
للحواسيب الكلاسيكية
بس في هذا الفصل راح نركز على نوعين
الأكثر شيوعًا: البرمجة المتوازية
وسير مهام. باستخدام هذين النموذجين
مع نماذج البرمجة الكمية
تقدر تعبر عن أي سير عمل هجين
كمي-كلاسيكي مهما كانت تعقيدية
نموذج البرمجة المتوازية
بيقسم البرنامج لمسائل فرعية ممكن تتنفذ
في نفس الوقت. في نوعين رئيسيين للبرمجة المتوازية
الذاكرة المشتركة والذاكرة الموزعة
لأغراضنا هنا راح نركز على نموذج الذاكرة الموزعة
نموذج الذاكرة الموزعة
بيستخدم عمليات مستقلة على أنوية منفصلة
أو عُقد، كل عملية عندها ذاكرتها الخاصة
والتواصل بيصير عن طريق تمرير الرسائل. في
بعض المفاهيم اللي مفيد تعرفها
الأول هو الـ process
وهو نسخة مستقلة من البرنامج
بتشتغل على نواة منفصلة
وكمان الـ rank وهو معرّف فريد للعملية
وبعدين في نموذج برنامج واحد
بيانات متعددة SPMD
وهو نموذج تجريدي
للحوسبة حيث نسخة واحدة من البرنامج
بتتوزع على عدة عُقد
فالكود المصدري نفسه
لكن البيانات على هذي العُقد مختلفة
نموذج البرمجة المتوازية بالتنفيذ
بيصير بالطريقة التالية
برنامج واحد بيتوزع على عدة عُقد
ويبدأ عمليات متوازية متعددة
تدفق التحكم في البرنامج بيتحكم فيه الـ rank
أو معرّف العملية
والتواصل بيصير
عن طريق تمرير الرسائل
نموذج برمجة سير مهام
بيجرد الحوسبة في شكل رسم بياني أو DAG
كل عقدة في الرسم البياني هي مهمة محددة
أو وظيفة والأطراف هي التبعيات والبيانات
والترتيب. أمثلة موجودة في توثيقنا
بعد كل شيء، التسلسل اللي نتكلم عنه دائمًا في الكم
هو: التعيين، التحسين،
التنفيذ، والمعالجة اللاحقة
هو نموذج برمجة سير مهام
حيث كل المهام بتتنفذ واحدة بعد
الأخرى في الـ pipeline
لكن مع سير المهام
مش مضطرين للتنفيذ المتسلسل
ونقدر ننفذ مهام بالتوازي
كل مهمة أو سير عمل ممكن تكون وظيفة متوازية كاملة
لحالها، فتقدر تمزج
وتطابق هذي النماذج لتصف الخوارزميات
بأي درجة من التعقيد.
جرب نطبق بعض المفاهيم اللي تعلمناها
على الكود. أول شيء راح نجرب نشغل hello world بسيط
باستخدام نموذج البرمجة المتوازية
راح نستخدم Open MPI
اللي هو تطبيق لبروتوكول MPI
وهو المعيار لتمرير الرسائل
في البرمجة المتوازية
أول شيء لازم يكون عندنا برنامجنا جاهز
هنا نستخدم mpi4py
اللي هو binding لـ Python
لـ MPI وكما تشوف نستخدم الـ rank هنا لنقرر
تدفق التحكم في البرنامج
نتفحص سكريبت الإرسال بتاعنا.
كما تشوف راح نستخدم عقدتين
مهمة واحدة لكل عقدة في الـ normal partition
نشغل البرنامج. راح ننتظر شوية
ونقدر نشوف نتائج وظيفتنا
كما تشوف عندنا مخرجات log لبرنامجنا
هنا استخدمنا عقدتين وعمليتين
متعرفتين بالـ rank
كما تشوف هنا في المخرجات
rank zero وrank one اللي استخدمناهم نقرر
تدفق التحكم في برنامجنا
كما تشوف العملية rank zero أرسلت
payload لعملية rank one
وعملية rank one استلمته
الـ payload ده. نتكلم كمان عن سير المهام
في أدوات تُسمى أنظمة
إدارة سير العمل، مصممة خصيصًا
لتشغيل سير عمل معقدة
لكن عشان ما نثقل عليك راح نستخدم ميزة
التبعيات المدمجة في Slurm
لبناء هذي المجموعات الحسابية
أول شيء نحتاج تكون عندنا مهام سير العمل
جاهزة. هذا نفس الكود
ميزة وجود كل مهمة من هذي المهام
من تعيين وتحسين وتنفيذ
ومعالجة لاحقة كخطوات منفصلة
هي إننا نقدر نحدد متطلبات موارد فريدة
لكل مهمة. مثلًا التعيين والتحسين
والمعالجة اللاحقة ما تحتاج
وصول لموارد كمية
فبالتالي نقدر نشغلها على الـ classical partition.
لكن مهمة التنفيذ تحتاج
موارد كمية فراح نشغلها على الـ quantum
partition.
الآن نستخدم ميزة التبعيات لنربط المهام
في سير عمل.
كما تشوف لسه شغّال
أمر الـ sbatch بتاعنا مع الـ flag المناسب
اللي راح يرجع لنا الـ job ID
وبعدين نقدر نمرر هذا الـ job ID
كتبعية لمهام أخرى
كما تشوف نشغل
وظائف في سير العمل بالتبعية
لما يكتمل سير العمل بالكامل نقدر نشوف النتائج.
وكما تشوف عندنا قيمة التوقع راجعة لينا.
ونقدر كمان نتحقق من كل
النتائج من كل خطوة.
وهي موجودة هنا كمان.
وهذا كان قسم نماذج البرمجة
في الفصل القادم راح نتكلم عن الخوارزميات
المتقدمة